police in San Diego have arrested a 24
year old man who they say stabbed and
killed a young woman inside her home
here in Las Vegas it happened last night
near MLK in Washington Victoria Saha
spoke with a victim's family who
identifies her as 21-year-old Michaela
Adams
so many unanswered questions tonight
about this young mother's murder and as
her family copes with their loss they
hope the person responsible pays the
consequences she was my baby cousin
she had her own life to live Crystal
Adams showed up to the house where her
cousin Michaela was murdered Tuesday
night it's news she still doesn't want
to believe is true she left behind a
little girl and family that cared about
her so much this is not fair it's not
fair at all she didn't deserve this she
was a beautiful person police say
Michaela's parents found her when they
came home her little girl was also
inside but unharmed the man accused
24-year-old Michael Ricks he took off to
San Diego investigators say Rick's is
Michaela's ex-boyfriend he came to the
house and the two started to argue then
he allegedly stabbed her that's not fair
you don't deserve you don't do that to
somebody that you supposedly Love
video showing Rick's being arrested
Wednesday morning by San Diego Police
they say they received a tip that a man
with a warrant from Las Vegas was inside
a home when Rick's tried to leave that's
when police stopped him meanwhile
Michaela's heartbroken family has some
words for Ricks you'll get what you
deserve you kill the innocent Angel
friends and family will be gathering
later tonight right here on the corner
of Rita McWilliams to honor Michaela
with a candlelight vigil Victoria sahab
8 News Now
thank you Victoria Ricks will be
extradited to Las Vegas where he will
face an open murder charge